hello and a very warm welcome to world
stories i'm laila Hawkwood your
international reporters magazine
straight ahead a success story from
yemen cooking on sunshine in costa rica
beauty with a mission in burkina faso
and a mind-blowing proposal in bulgaria
but first a group of computer nerds in
australia throw a party it goes viral
and now it's an international phenomenon
you may never have heard of crypto
parties before but you should during
these get-togethers ordinary internet
users ilorin how to protect a privacy
online the goal to empower people to
control their personal information
because as SBS reporter Andy park shows
us without realizing it online we often
reveal things we don't choose to reveal
what was once the domain of classified
wartime secrecy or hidden away in
mathematics Labs is now the pursuit of
an exploding global movement in Sydney
code makers and breakers of the virtual
world are materializing this is a crypto
party it's a grassroots DIY session
where ordinary internet users gather to
learn how to encrypt their personal data
protecting it from governments
corporations and other users they
believe that privacy is a right their
knowledge base is crowd-sourced and
they're trying to put the personal back
into personal computing and that's what
the crypto pays about making some these
messages simple and sharing that
information and trying to get past the
technical jargon it all started in
Melbourne and this is one of 40
gatherings that's popped up since then
in cities across the globe in fact
parties like these are happening on the
same day in Reykjavik Brussels and
Manila basically it was just a
conversation that happened on Twitter
and I expected it to be a really small
thing that was just amongst my friends
and it's taken off and it's now global
more and more privacy is being taken
back into the hands of users encryption
is the science of changing data so it's
unusable by anyone except the authorized
recipient the sender either uses a
publicly available pool of keys or makes
their own and the
trend is extending across hard drive
encryption email and chat protection
browser history and even using your
mobile phone yeah this is but crypto
parties are not exclusive to a younger
generation privacy is a very important
issue for me whether it's on the
internet or on the phone do you have to
be a hacker to be into encryption no I
don't think so not at all but is it
teaching cyber criminals to hide their
tracks I think those that want to break
the law have already probably learnt
cryptography people like myself and
other law abiding citizens basically are
the ones left on the hard end of the
stick who not only are having their
privacy evade by government and business
but also don't have those sort of skills
previously to protect their own privacy
so if you've got curtains on your
bedroom windows it's because you've got
something to hide it doesn't necessarily
mean doing anything wrong that's
personal privacy a trend that seeing
internet users learning how to be privus
out in the open well let's move to Yemen
our country not known for its success
stories one of the poorest nations in
the Arab world it always seems on the
brink of collapse it's a place where
women cover up in public and are not
often in the limelight so when a Yemeni
woman won the Nobel Peace Prize back in
2011 the world took notice but she's not
alone there are other fiery fearless and
ambitious women challenging the status
quo in his deeply conservative society
as nabila you Sophie from a lion TV
discovered when he sat down with a
newswoman who's breaking barriers Yemeni
women faced many challenges Russ Mia
al-maliki has met and overcome many of
them in the course of her television
career now she's become the head
presenter at Yemen's state satellite
channel Saba since I've become head
presenter I've never felt out of place
or uncomfortable in any situation I
enjoy the same respect recognition and
cooperation from my co-workers at no
point have I gotten the feeling that
I've been left to fend for myself or
that I'm not appreciated in my new
position resmia al Mulla iki has been
fighting the glass ceiling of a strict
email dominated workplace for 15 years
when it comes to women's rights Yemen is
considered one of the most unequal
societies in the world but with the help
of her family and her professional
abilities Roz Mia's one respect and
recognition what is the image of women
working in the media the attitude toward
men working in the media is quite
different men are respected and accepted
but women are seen as incompetent
whether they're a reporter in the field
or a journalist they're regarded as
unable to have an opinion and incapable
of working at this profession not to
mention that they're going against the
norm thank goodness i had the support of
my family and my father so i never had
to worry about the prevailing attitudes
al Mulla Ickes co-workers at saba have
come to know and value their superior
for her dedication to the job and this
recognition is an incentive for her to
do more and better yeah but I'm tell me
he's a pooka he's very good yemeni
society hardly ever entrusts a woman
with a leadership position alambagh but
she's been very successful in the
presenters Department I'm so all the
presenters at saba are good like but Roz
Mia is the most highly regarded of all
ha tomorrow Tamia here smear Roz mia
al-maliki gives Yemeni women some of the
blame for their failure to make progress
saying some passively accept
conservative Yemeni customer osmia
al-maliki succeeded by virtue of her own
abilities but she says her victory
belongs to those Yemeni women who have
fought for their rights it's free it's
abundant and it's everywhere solar
energy one country would more than its
share of sunshine is costa rica in the
Central American nation one woman is now
stirring things up with a bright idea
using solar energy
cooking fatima monte alegre has set out
to harness the sun's clean affordable
and sustainable energy and as Gabriela
Perez from Costa Rica's canal 15 reports
the entrepreneur solar cooking stoves
are a glowing success the Sun is a
source of light heat and ultimately of
life on Earth in Costa Rica's guanacaste
province the weather is mostly sunny and
dry this is where Fatima Monte Alegre
and her family live she's collected a
great deal of experience using solar
cookers Joseph isn't at all I support
the use of solar energy I work with
groups of women to build solar cookers I
encourage them to take part in projects
like these I've managed to learn
something and I want to share what I've
learned with the women of other
communities and I've passed it on to my
own family as well the exploitation of
the earth's resources is taking an
increasing toll in its environment and
climate Costa Rica's 2010 report on the
state of the nation declared that if
this country is to achieve zero co2
emissions you will have to find
eco-friendly ways to generate power
reduce the burning of wood and reform
transportation
wanna go see de Sol our tenemos la
oportunidad the solar cooker is one way
to utilize a natural clean and healthy
source of energy like sunlight it's
important for a family to have a solar
cooker at home it reduces the need for
firewood which in turn helps to slow
down the destruction of the forests and
slow down global warming and it's good
for their health because food cooked
this way is healthier and this is also
about helping to protect natural
resources right here at home there are
various types of solar cookers that can
reach temperatures from 150 to 400
degrees Celsius depending on the time of
day the season the air and the weather
conditions estes una cocina Solarte
porno contra de this is a solar cooker
of the oven time we local women built it
ourselves the same way the nearby casa
de la Sol ecotourism project did it uses
direct sunlight collects it here and
reflects it down here escena this solar
cooker consists of an exterior box and
interior chamber a black plate and most
important of all this reflector it
stands on a frame that lets us turn it
toward the Sun that way we can make the
optimal use of the light and reach 150
degrees that's the maximum temperature
this oven can cook at
using this kind of solar cooker for
seven months can save up to eleven
hundred kilowatts of energy 240 litres
of natural gas or 725 kilograms of
firewood it doesn't contribute to global
warming or climate change because it
releases no greenhouse gases this is an
sk14 parabolic oven the pot goes in here
and it can reach a temperature of 350
degrees Celsius Danya fatima isn't the
only woman in guanacaste working along
the same lines more and more people are
turning to ecological energy sources
they're showing the way for ordinary
citizens both men and women to help
protect the environment for me the solar
cooker opened a window of opportunity to
learn new things and to develop along
with it we have to stop and think about
how to protect our natural resources and
our planet a planet with so many
god-given riches we can't just sit on
our hands and watch it be destroyed so
I'm doing my part no matter how small it
is and you think it isn't important in
fact it is women in West Africa know the
secret to smooth and soft skin shea
butter once a little-known product it
has become a beauty industry favorite
and butter from the shea nut is lifting
women out of poverty in Burkina Faso
women do most of the work in harvesting
and processing the nuts in the country
and a significant percentage of the
global sale proceeds goes to a women's
cooperative there that income allows the
shea butter producers to take care of
their families and to provide food and
education for their children Mike muser
and Marie ango report for TVs at Africa
the small town of Leo in southern
Burkina Faso lives from the nuts of the
shea tree the nuts have transformed the
lives of many local women among them 59
year old lady
in 2001 lady joined a group of local
women to found the new nuna organization
and mechanized production of shea butter
now the organization has more than 4,000
members lady has to work hard but she's
happy alvina you still I said this one I
ride my bicycle so I get in some
exercise if I stay at home I'd age even
faster I hope I can carry on working
here for a long time it keeps me fit
getting organized enabled these women to
tap assistance from NGOs and buy large
machines that made the shea butter
production process here much more
efficient
a visit to the nearby village of W shows
how hard it used to be the women here
still make shea butter just as they have
for centuries they even have to make
their own tools as in most of the other
villages that people here make almost
everything by hand they work hard and
make barely enough to survive the women
don't sing just to entertain themselves
but to set the pace for their work and
support each other
lady is here to offer her support she
serves as an advisor and contact person
for the village women never I'm travell
kwanzaa Japan's oh come on cos this is
how we used to work before we got the
big machines give me a la sit there on
their faces thank God that changed in
2001 city money it's really hard work to
crush the nuts by hand shea butter is a
traditional local product used in
cooking because of its high fat content
it's in high demand for export as well
abroad it's mainly used in cosmetic
products making shea butter has always
been women's work whether by tradition
or in New nuna the organization has
grown and is now able to produce shea
butter on a large scale and that has
paid off
nor through actually now we're only
producing for export our main customer
is the French brand looks aight on the
french by about eighty percent of our
shea butter notice even tougher another
customer is so feeble also in france and
we sell to canada as well we also
produce our own soap from shea butter we
sell that locally and to France once
again the moment of truth for these
workers has come the shea butter they've
produced over the past few days is
weighed the women work in groups and
each group is paid by the weight of
their product they don't concern
themselves with the export or marketing
the new new non directors take care of
that
in this way the women can collect their
pay quickly and directly
everyone in ladies family is up well
before 7am as a widow lady alone
provides for her family she takes her
grandson to school every day before she
goes to work when we've got enough
orders I have no trouble financing our
lives here but she is well aware that
she couldn't do it without new nuna nor
could she afford to send her grandson to
school his education is one of her top
priorities she wants him to have a
better future even so she is optimistic
and satisfied with her life seeking wash
yo kwon fair city and what I hope for
myself is that will keep getting lots of
orders and maybe someday I'll be able to
afford a little motorcycle or a car that
I can use to drive to work even now lady
has already set an example for the women
of Leo
when authorities and the Philippines
moved forward with plans to make
kindergarten mandatory there they
overlooked a pressing issue lack of
space students in the country were
already crammed into classrooms and the
new law has put additional pressure on
an already critical situation to ease
overcrowding officials have now
introduced temporary mobile facilities
turning trucks to makeshift classrooms
reporter Anika took a look at how it
works in a suburb of Manila children
attend class in the converted truck they
and their teachers like being outside in
the fresh air it's far better than
trying to concentrate while being cooped
up in a sweltering classroom I think
this solution is conducive to learning
because the kids are relaxed and not
crammed into a hot classroom the truck
is a temporary solution to a problem
widespread in the Philippines
overcrowded classrooms with an average
of forty two children to a room Corazon
Aquino elementary is no exception and
since a law took effect requiring all
children to attend kindergarten things
are getting worse there is simply not
enough space
so the Education Ministry launched its
kindergarten on wheels project situation
where you don't have enough space so you
need to be creative and think of
projects like this the Education
Ministry pays 800 thousand pesos or more
than fifteen thousand euros to convert
one truck and that includes all the
modern classroom equipment even a
television but unless more financial
support is forthcoming the trucks will
overflow even faster than the classrooms
when if we can add additional 100,000
pesos more it could be bigger so that it
won't be as crowded so that is my man
ambitious to make it bigger but since we
are budget country
the nexus one problem that we have the
case event dress the aquino school still
doesn't have enough room so it's hard to
reintroduce the shift system from 6am
till 6pm the students come for a
three-hour school day it's the only way
for the school to accommodate all the
children half of them in the classroom
half of them in the truck this truck is
the only mobile classroom so far
sponsors are needed to finance more so
every child will have a seat in a
schoolroom as mandated by law many
people only get one shot at it asking
the one you love to marry you but for a
man in Bulgaria high on love getting
down on one knee and proposing the
old-fashioned way just wasn't enough
Nova TVs jeffco konstantinov has this
story on winning hearts by going that
extra mile she's 25 years old from the
port city of varna and works in a
medical laboratory he's 27 also from
Varna and a graphic designer Mariana and
yaasiin met through mutual friends and
the chemistry was immediate they've been
together for eight years now they both
watched Nova's documentary about
parachuting and decided to try their
hand except that yaasiin has another
motive an idea that he's kept secret he
wants to ask Mariana to marry him after
a jump Mariana has no clue what's coming
Mariana are you going to jump who made
you do this I wanted to but he insisted
as well yeah I'm to blame men are always
to blame Mariana prepares to board the
plane she'll jump from 3,500 metres
above ground level
meanwhile yaasiin has a surprise in
store while Marianas flying high he gets
ready to pop the question
I'm preparing the message I want my
beloved to see the moment she lands or
maybe just before that so she realizes
what she's seen
what does it say it's the standard
message every woman wants to hear will
you marry me that's what I wrote bossman
dr. Selar is it outside a while
preparations on the ground are in full
swing the plane door opens they'll reach
speeds of 240 kilometers an hour they
work up their courage and jump into
freefall
parachute
now wait and see if she says yes adi
touka absolute don't you are waiting and
hoping she will say yes you don't always
get what you wish for things like a
thorough stop what will you do if she
says no another attempt another time
another place this is what awaited
Mariana
I will kill him come on answer my
question a hundred times yes
I
think about it every
I tried to get rid of you I threw you
out of a plane with a parachute but I
failed this is it will you marry me
I've been
we wish the happy couple all the best
ostrov a Bulgaria Mariana yeah so cheap
all's well that ends well we wish the
lovebirds all the happiness in the world
and that just about wraps up this week's
program thanks for joining us as always
don't forget that if you want to watch
the show again all you have to do is
head to our website but before we go
here at this week's picks of the world
from the streets of India see you next
time
you